welcome welcome back to the second path
of our holiday two-part series holiday
extravaganza for short arrow we got your
George we got Gil Gil we got Clark lie
and I um I have a confession to make
yeah my confession is that I I haven't
played destiny in about a week and I'm
done
officially I think I'm done I've been
playing Skyrim great again and I played
it years ago and they released it on
Xbox one and I'm having fun with that
and um I'm just done I'm didn't feel
nauseous won't even you think about
destiny and I'm done just to let you
guys know and um its growth for me as a
person and um also it's the New Year's
coming right new year resolutions you
have resolutions for each other for
ourselves
all right first week okay go ahead I'm
sorry for interrupting paper but there's
one problem that I have that I've been
doing it since I was a baby is I lie a
lot mm-hmm and I can't stop do you think
they're black or white lies
well yeah what's the difference white
lies are little things that don't affect
the overall outcome of someone's like
like they're not damning lies they're
not they're not gonna ruin anyone's life
then they're gray my lives are my lies
are sometimes gray they're mixed no ed
no they're pretty white it's like um
like hey make my makeup a movie and say
did you see it to me hey did you see the
Charlie's water yeah man whoo hey do
like why would I lie about that yeah
yeah but that's the stuff that I do did
you check out that new album by a
Kentucky ranch also good yeah real good
like we're both lying
those are pretty wise you guys you guys
Lionel Rossum right I made up a band he
said that he liked it never heard of it
before
right so it's those kind of
that I know why do I do that and also
like stories that some of my stories
just exaggerations in it elephants right
to make it more exciting
you know so I don't know if that's
something that I can change about myself
I think the best storytellers are people
that embellish yeah
and also it's like I want to name-drop
Rogan told me at the UFC Rogan told me
once life is a movie just look at it
like you're in a movie right I do this
movies Westworld you know it's so weird
cuz when he gets confronted about a lie
he continues to lie even if there's hard
evidence it's one of those things so I
don't know what you're talking about I
don't know what you and it's like no you
literally texted this girl that you want
a raw dog her like it's right in front
of my face
let me raw dog ur like no con what do
you mean ike in the beginning of our
relationship you would lie like why raw
dog how do you explain that and he would
feel guilty like I remember one time
he's like I haven't been to a strip club
and so long and I'm like no you can go
if you want like I don't that doesn't
really threaten me so he went to Texas
with an opener and he obviously went to
a strip club and I know that he lied
about it because the next day he changed
his status on facebook to in a
relationship and in my head I'm like oh
he for sure has guilt in my heart
there's only one reason why and I'll
tell you why George the best I ever got
treated by a man was a weekend after he
cheated on me and all of a sudden he
wanted to get me a motorcycle all of a
sudden he wanted to get me a timeshare
and that's when I became suspicious and
I thought to myself what is motorcycle
do you babe but you that would never
happen
that's weird he's weird yeah like we
went to the Harley store you know and it
was it was like it made me suspicious
not because I don't think that you know
you can't do nice things for your
partner
it was too much it was almost as if like
you can tell when someone's trying to
cover up something and they're trying to
overcompensate and so I I sure enough he
had cheated on me so I become very
suspicious when people just go when you
go off script of their usual and all of
a sudden they're being so kind their
relationship isn't getting better he
just he just might have done something
I've never cheated on you okay I'm not
saying that you did I never did why her
nose so deep you know why cuz he doesn't
want his nose to grow like Pinocchio oh
that's clever
Disney reference yeah I've never cheat
on you I would never cheat on you no no
I'm not we're over that like they're so
[ __ ] far beyond that I'm just talking
about I don't even now follow girls on
Instagram that are hot because she'll
know and I've never told you not to I
know but still there's like why'd you
follow someone so I never said that I
never never never said that it was only
one time after a trip from Toronto where
you told me that the club manager had
had a girl for you that weekend that was
assigned to you and then you started
following that girl so in my head I'm
like did he have sex with this girl
because she's a very pretty girl so I'm
like oh it didn't make me feel good
inside Dalen Dornan no no that's not
what it is yeah it was in a no no the
girl that was at the club nope nope
Laura different story but I got in
trouble for that too because you took
you went to mall and took photographs
that you that's our thing you took
photographs with a girl a pretty girl
that I've never met before and posted it
on your Instagram as if like like I
don't know you you guys are like
gallivanting around town together taking
a ton of photos and we were just three
months together and I'm like whoa I feel
like chopped liver like I don't he
hasn't called me all day he's been
posting pictures of another woman ibaka
it doesn't make any I'm sorry
it doesn't make anybody right you're
right you're right and so obviously like
I think I'm a reasonable person and I
didn't attack you for it I just said hey
that's you know I'm I'm not accusing you
of anything but this [ __ ] doesn't feel
good you're right and that's all that
was the end of the discussion and also
the end of the discussion was why did
you text this girl that you wanted her
raw dog her we're in a relationship and
you said I don't know what you're
talking about I just job so yeah you all
you do have a lying part about you but I
think that it's more deceiving than
lying that's fine yeah yeah yes
[Music]